[Musik]
der König ist da samt Familie doch der
Termin läuft anders als geplant
[Musik]
Stimme einer Studentin stört das
Protokoll ihre Faust stellt eine
Forderung auf
der König müsse sich entschuldigen für
die Rolle der Niederlande in der
Sklaverei die Szene an der Universität
von Aruba ist ein Symbol
die Niederländer streiten gerade über
das Bild dass sie von ihrem Land haben
der Streit reißt mit als Wilhelm
Alexander Ende Januar eine Boeing landet
Aruba bonere Curacao und drei kleinere
Inseln sind der karibische Teil des
Königreichs der Besuch hat Tradition es
ist wie königstag in anderer Kulisse
die Familie tanzt sich durch den
Karneval setzt sich für die gute Sache
ein doch sie geht auch dorthin wo
Geschichte wehtut an die Orte eines der
größten Verbrechen der Menschheit der
Sklaverei
im 17 Jahrhundert waren Niederländer
tief verstrickt in den transatlantischen
Sklavenhandel sie legten geschätzt
600.000 Menschen in Ketten brandmarkten
sie als ihren Besitz das Bild vom
Goldenen Zeitalter hat Risse bekommen
Nachfahren versklavter Menschen treten
aus dem Schatten sie klagen an
denn hach im Dezember danach wolle er
sich äußern sagt Marc rütte nach seiner
Rede im Nationalarchiv von Dach bietet
Name
der niederländischen Regierung um
Entschuldigung für das Handeln des
niederländischen Staates in der
Vergangenheit und Post um bei allen
versklavten Menschen weltweit bei ihren
Töchtern und Söhnen und alle Nachfahren
bis ins Hier und Heute
der Moment des historisch erstmals
entschuldigt sich der Regierungschef
einer europäischen Nation für die
Sklaverei und das in allen Sprachen der
Nachbarn
diese Rede müssen der Anfang sein kein
Ende der Debatte so die Reaktionen vor
Ort es brauche jetzt Wertschätzung
Anerkennung Respekt viele sind bewegt
doch der Termin ist auch schnell beendet
und gerade im karibischen Teil des
Königreichs sind nicht alle überzeugt
Curacao ist die größte Insel wir fahren
auf die ärmliche Seite
pernell satonino ist Schlagzeuger
grammy-preisträger
dieser verlassene Ort sagt er sei ideal
um tamboo zu spielen
seine Vorfahren brachten die Musik über
das Meer sie spendet Trost und gebe Mut
ist
über deinen Schmerz das war Tambo
[Musik]
der Takt des Tabu einte die versklavten
Menschen und
ängstigte die Unterdrücker
[Musik]
tanzen singen schreien lachen
sie dachten oh jetzt bereiten sie
womöglich einen Aufstand vor also ist es
wohl besser Ihnen das zu verbieten
die verbotene Musik ist heute der
Soundtrack einer geschichtsdebatte
[Musik]
sein Henrikes ist darin eine wichtige
Stimme die Historikerin kritisiert den
Premier und seine Entschuldigung aus dem
Dezember das Datum sei willkürlich
gewesen die Worte beiläufig ihre Meinung
wichtig ist dass man darüber nachdenkt
dass man nicht einfach so sorry tut mir
leid sagt
man muss auf alle Aspekte der
Gräueltaten Hinweisen in der Wirtschaft
der Gesellschaft der Kultur und der
Justiz
etwas kulturell es war ein System in dem
Menschen zu wahren wurden
sie ist Gast im Lokalfernsehen die
Entschuldigung ist auch hier das Thema
die Sklaverei wurde vor 150 Jahren
abgeschafft das Jubiläum im Sommer wäre
ideal meint die Moderatorin in der
Werbepause
aus ecket
machen und auf andere Weise schickt
nicht irgendeinen Staatssekretär nein
dafür muss der König kommen und dann
geht ein neues Gespräch los
auf der Nachbarinsel bonere ist sie
schon da die Königsfamilie das
Inselmuseum serviert zur Suppe auch
Geschichte über die mörderische Arbeit
in den Salzpfannen vor und nach der
Abschaffung des Sklaverei die Gäste
zeigen Interesse und die Insel ihre
Zuneigung
hellen angela ist Nachfahren von Sklaven
und Fan der Orange ist für sie kein
Widerspruch
so erfahren Sie wie es um uns steht was
hier passiert ist
dies sind keine Strandhäuser es sind
Hütten versklavter Menschen die auf der
Insel Salz schürfen mussten hier treffen
wir hellen Angela noch einmal die enge
sagt sie war Absicht das ist nicht hoch
man konnte nicht drin stehen zum
schlafen musste man reinkriechen
heute sind ein Fünftel der Insel und
auch dieser historische Ort bedroht der
Meeresspiegel steigt
im Wasser stehen
was heißt das für sie
das bedeutet dass ein großer Teil
unserer Geschichte verschwindet
Helen angela hat sich einer Klage
angeschlossen damit will sie die
Regierung zwingen das Land vor dem Meer
zu schützen was in Europa die erste
staatspflicht ist das müsse auch in der
Karibik gelten
so sangen versklavte Menschen bei der
Ernte Jeanne Henrikes die Historikerin
von Curacao will hier von Tula erzählen
einem Anführer der 1795 den Aufstand
wagte die Französische Revolution hatte
sich rumgesprochen in den Hügeln rings
um dieses Landhaus Tula forderte
Freiheit Gleichheit Brüderlichkeit und
endete auf der Streckbank
warum müssen wir so etwas erleben warum
müssen wir so leiden das zeigt seine
Persönlichkeit seine Menschen liebe
obwohl er wusste dass er bestraft werden
würde setzte er sich noch für andere
einsetzt
die Geschichte der Landhäuser gibt
Vorbilder und werte sie sollen Curacao
leiten seit 2010 heißt das Ziel
Unabhängigkeit
doch in der Kulisse der Kreuzfahrer geht
noch immer nichts ohne die Niederlande
nicht in der Wirtschaft und nicht in der
Bildung
die Jungen wie diese kunstschüler im
benachteiligten Stadtteil Buena Vista
müssen die Insel noch immer verlassen
wenn sie weiterkommen wollen
Juna Albertus hofft auf einen Platz an
der Kunstakademie in Utrecht
ihr Lehrer Tür somater will ihr dafür
Flügel geben und Wurzeln
ich will nicht zu den Studenten gehören
die in die Niederlande gehen und dort
ihre Kultur vergessen
mein Plan ist es zurückzukommen und
künftige Generationen zu beeinflussen
sowie Tür so das getan hat
Künstler mit Weltkarriere
Inspiration schöpft er auch aus der
Geschichte seiner Familie
befreit wurde sie vor vier Generationen
[Musik]
die Menschen kamen aus der Sklaverei
doch dann mussten sie mit alten
Abhängigkeiten klarkommen die ist ja
noch immer in der Gesellschaft Gabe
und ihr Leben gemeistert haben
die Abschaffung der Sklaverei war nicht
das Ende der Geschichte
Schlagzeuger Panel sardonino im Museum
des tambu Musik und Trommel gleichen
Namens blieben noch lange verboten
manche sagt mir aber wenn ihr meinen
tambu kaputt macht dann lebe ich meine
Kultur anders aus ich spiele auf dem
Stuhl auf der Blechdose den Teller auf
meiner Kiste
unkaputtbar und zensierbar Tabu ist noch
heute verpönt die Kirche tat alles dafür
sie versuchten es mit Hirnwäsche sie
sagten den Menschen das ist falsch das
ist des Teufels das ist gegen die Natur
das ist nicht gut für dich voll gemein
im Weg
eine Entschuldigung können nur der
Anfang sein meint der Schlagzeuger die
Niederländer aber auch die Bewohner der
Insel müssten sich klar werden wo
Sklaverei fortwirkt nur dann könnten Sie
sich von der Last der Geschichte
befreien
dies wäre ein Ort dafür aus Dornen aus
dieser Geschichte was Neues schaffen
soll diese Kathedrale
kreative Geister versammelt Hermann van
Bärchen er kam vor über 30 Jahren auf
die Insel und lädt andere Künstler wie
türsomata ein hier auszustellen sich die
Hand zu reichen
ach das sollten wir viel öfter machen
Rassismus und sowas das gibt es nicht
unter uns Künstler
wir müssen uns als Menschen begegnen das
ist wichtig
wir sitzen hier zusammen auf Curacao wir
sehen das ganze Leid die Konflikte die
Korruption
die gemeinsame Geschichte
daraus müssen wir das Beste machen wir
teilen so viel miteinander
der König wird die dornkathedrale
besuchen diese beiden aber versöhnen
sich schon selbst
im Landhaus das ein Museum für Tula
werden soll erwarten Sie dagegen ein
Wort des Königs
das Staatsoberhaupt ist Teil der
Regierung sie sagte ihm was er sagen
darf in dieser Klemme ist schon der
Besuch allein eine Botschaft
die Gastgeberin Historikerin
jean-henrikes wagt es trotzdem
ich bitte Sie als erster König der Welt
am ersten Juli 2023 die vorherrschende
Stille zu durchbrechen
es wäre für uns sehr wichtig bitte
überlegen Sie sich das
der König verneigt sich mehr nicht ein
Schauspieler verkörpert noch den
Aufständischen bis zum ersten Juli hat
der König Zeit aus dieser Geschichte
seine leeren zu ziehen
[Musik]